we're going to begin this hour with an
historic weekend in music you never know
who's going to show up at the iconic
newport folk festival this year it was
two of the greatest singer-songwriters
of their generation the first surprise
well that came on saturday
[Music]
look at that crowd mesmerized that of
course is a great paul simon grace of
festival stage for the first time ever
joining nathaniel raitliff in the night
sweats and last night a real legend also
returned to the newport folk festival
stage for the first time in 53 years
that of course is the great joni
mitchell anthony mason was there anthony
good morning of course you were there
you go every single year but boy this
was a big deal
yeah this was amazing
you know the closing set at the newport
folk festival gale was billed as brandy
carlisle and friends but brandy had a
very big surprise and what happened next
was one of the most emotional concerts i
have ever experienced
and please welcome back to the newport
stage
for the first time since 1969.
when the surprise guest walked gingerly
onto the stage at the newport folk
festival the crowd erupted
then supported by an all-star cast of
musicians
78-year-old joni mitchell gave her first
public performance since a brain
aneurysm nearly killed her in 2015.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the stage was set up like joni's
california living room where the
recovering singer has been hosting joni
jams with fellow musicians for the past
few years and she just wants to sit
there and drink her wine and listen
right
but it didn't turn out like that she
started singing
and then she started playing
and brandi carlisle had the idea of
bringing the joni jam to newport you've
been thinking about this for quite a
while
i dreamed it the first time she opened
her mouth
and sang summertime
and i saw herbie hancock burst into
tears
and everybody in the room catch their
breath because she had decided to sing
really decided to sing you know
i knew
i knew she'd do it on newport
i can't really say how i knew it i just
pictured her out there i pictured the
water and the fort and the boats
[Music]
but until rehearsals friday night here
no one was sure she would feel up to it
including joni herself are you at all
nervous about singing in front of an
audience again no i've never been
nervous about being a caring audience
but i wanted to be good you know and i
wasn't sure that i could be but i didn't
sound too bad tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
joni was 23 when she first played
newport back in 1967.
yeah i met leonard cohen in 67 i met
james taylor in 69 yeah that's pretty
good company good friends for my life
in her first trip back in 53 years joni
played guitar a skill the aneurysm took
from her till only recently
[Music]
[Applause]
you taught yourself to play again i'm
i'm learning i i'm looking at videos
that are on the net to see what where i
put my fingers you know
it's amazing like what an aneurysm
knocks out
how to get out of a chair you don't know
how to get out of bed you don't know how
yeah you know i have to learn all these
things by road again you know i was into
water ballet as a kid
and
i i forgot how to do the breaststroke
every time i tried it i just got drowned
you know
so there's a lot of you going back to
infancy almost you have to relearn
everything how do you find the will to
do that
i don't know but the the the surgeon
that did did the brain surgery on me
i said
i said i had will and grit yeah you show
that every day
i think you have will and grit yeah i
think i do
she definitely does i've recovered from
a lot of things you know you sure have
polio at age nine polio left her
paralyzed joanie willed herself to walk
again your friends call you a miracle
[Laughter]
i love you jonah you magical thing
joni's career has been widely celebrated
this past year she was a kennedy center
honoree and music cares person of the
year at the grammys how did that feel
oh very rewarding you know
a lot of doors were shut to me like the
rockaway hall of fame they kept me out
of that for a long time so you're
feeling the love
i'm feeling the love yeah feels good it
feels good it's a beautiful thing to see
you're honored in this way i think
coming having a brush with death like
that kind of softens people towards me
the musicians at newport were as moved
as the audience marcus mumford handled
drums during the set how did it feel to
play with tony it's a it's a complete
dream and brandi is a wonderful
facilitator and leader and obviously
she's basically the one person in the
world who journey feels comfortable
sitting next to you to sing her songs
again and so i think it's
just really emotional
the crowd was joyful
and tearful
[Music]
especially when joni sang both sides now
what were you hoping to do by bringing
her here
johnny
hasn't always felt
the appreciation that exists
amongst humanity for her but i wanted
her to feel that
[Music]
by the end of the night everyone was
glowing
especially the artist herself
wow
it was
simply amazing i can't recall ever being
at a concert where both the women and
the men were crying at rehearsals on
friday night wynonna judd was crying so
were most of the musicians i was crying
not just because of what joni's music
has meant to people but beca or because
of how far she's come but because of how
good she sounded and everybody was
joyful about that
i think the doctor was right when he
said she had will and grit but i love
anthony when she said i think i sounded
pretty good there was no arrogance in
that she's just really speaking from the
heart about how she felt and going
online to look up her own videos to see
where she put her hands that was such a
wonderful conversation with all of them
and brandi carlisle and that gorgeous
robe that she had on really really nice
yeah i got to say when joanie got up to
play guitar and i'd seen it in
rehearsals friday night
i i got chills bartlett i mean as i said
because of how she good how good she
sounded because as she explained of all
that she's been through and literally it
was only months ago that she really got
to that point to play like that again
both sides now yeah i know i mean i
don't know how there could be a dry eye
in the house anthony hearing joni
mitchell perform both sides now in that
way and it's 78 to feel the love and to
know how much she's loved that was
really a beautiful lovely lovely weekend
anthony we appreciate you thank you so
much